[Music]
it is time for this week's pet project
amy lee joins us from nspca
she brought along someone who needs a
safe and good home and this is the first
time i've heard of this breed
called a puggle right it's it's a pug
and a beagle combined
you got it yeah this is and he's the
sweetest boy he's
a chunky i mean i keep i'm sitting here
just like rubbing on because he's so
cute and chubby
um but tosser is the sweetest 10 year
old man
he is just a gentleman he's so friendly
and
i mean we can't wait to find him a home
he's just great with
everybody i mean he's just
he agrees with me yeah he is speaking up
for himself he doesn't need you to sell
him he's got this
what am i doing here right he does he
looks he just looks sweet he looks like
he's just a sweet sweet dog
he likes trees yeah and he would be
great in a home
really with anybody he just has to be
the only dog he is
you know for a chunky little guy like
this he has napoleon complex so he
really thinks he's a big dog
and so we just would prefer him to be
the only dog and really he's all the dog
that you need i mean this guy is so
sweet and he wants to be the center of
attention
um he loves treats he could stand to
lose a few pounds but he's adorable
is he okay around kids do we know that
yeah he should be you know as long as
they're you know just
just always respect their space you know
i think it's parents responsibility to
make sure that they
know how to handle um any animal really
but he's great i mean he's great with
anybody family dog well the good news is
now people
can go for in-person visits and actually
spend time
with tosser and any other of the animals
that you're adopting
right so what you do is you go on our
website and you would put down the name
of the dog that you're interested in in
this case tosser hopefully
um he'll be available starting tomorrow
and you can come in and meet him and if
he's the right fit for your family you
know we'd love for him to go home
love it and always i love hearing about
the great homes that dogs like tosser go
to so thanks so much for
introducing us to him today amy if
you're interested in adopting a pet just
go to nevadaspca.org
starting tomorrow and you can also call
them at that
phone number 702-873-7722
rocky